[Musik]
momente von schwerer krankheit und not
sind oft auch momente von existenziellen
fragen die auseinandersetzung mit dem
sinn des lebens etwa nachdem bei seinem
trägt und wer man ist solche fragen und
ungewissheiten löst jeder anders aber
nicht selten spielt die religion dabei
eine rolle
in der schweiz kommt in solchen
situationen schon seit mehreren jahren
spiritual care zum zuge
aber schließt man damit nicht jene aus
die mit spiritualität nichts am hut
haben
darüber spreche ich jetzt mit zwei
frauen die es wissen müssen diese wellen
not professorin für seelsorge und ulrike
towson humanistische beraterin guten
morgen schön dass sie da sind ja sie
beide sind ja expertinnen wenn es darum
geht schwierige gespräche zu beginnen
und deswegen frage ist ja auch gleich
selber wo und wie beginnt man eigentlich
richtig vernarrt ein schwieriges
gespräch beginnt man mit einer guten
vorbereitung
das heißt es geht darum sich zuerst zu
vergewissern bin ich imstande bin ich
wirklich bereit diese personen meine
ungeteilte aufmerksamkeit zukommen zu
lassen
das ist der erste schritt war 1000 was
ist ihre meinung wie begegnen sie ein
gutes gespräch kann frau not durchaus
zustimmen gute vorbereitung vor allem in
der hinsicht dass die eigene einstellung
betrifft also dass innerhalb beim
eigenen gemütszustand ist sehr sehr
wichtig abgesehen davon ist natürlich
aber kann man sich nie 100 prozentig auf
das jeweilige gespräche vorbereiten und
man nie ganz genau weiß was was einem
begegnen wird wer einen begegnen wird
aber wenn man die eigene einstellung
wenn man die wenn die stimmt hat man
schon viel erreicht
ich persönlich finde auch blickkontakt
sehr wichtig zu versuchen auszustrahlen
dass ich dem anderen so vorurteilsfrei
und unvoreingenommen wie möglich zu höre
einfach dem anderen das gefühl zu geben
dass er die möglich dass sie die
möglichkeit hat
was ich von mensch zu mensch mit mir zu
unterhalten nicht in eine schublade
gesteckt zu werden sondern einfach
mensch sein zu können das ist für mich
also da da geht es mir eigentlich darum
und das also in meiner erfahrung ich
mache meinen beruf seit 21 jahren ist
das auch also funktioniert das dann auch
meistens aber eben sie deuten es quasi
an es gibt immer die möglichkeit des
scheiterns
jetzt frage ich mich sie beide und es
hier haben lange zeit seelsorge gemacht
christliche seelsorge sind inzwischen
eben quasi nur noch akademisch tätig und
sie haben es schon angedeutet sind sehr
lange schon humanistische beraterin
wie kommt man denn zu einer solchen
tätigkeit weswegen haben sie zu tun
begonnen was sie tun oder eben taten
bei mir war es so dass ich nach meinem
studium wo die letzten jahre rechts mit
hindernissen verlaufen und das ist jetzt
ein psychologischer technologie studiert
in deutschland habe dann zwei jahre vor
ende meines studiums meinen mann
kennengelernt der berge ist und bin
schwanger geworden also das ist ganz
viel gleichzeitig passiert und dann war
ich sehr froh mein studium dann doch zu
einem guten ende gelangt ist und recht
kurz danach habe ich bei der
organisation angefangen wo ich jetzt
seit 21 jahren arbeite und was hat mich
daran angesprochen dass es um wirklich
die existenziellen fragen geht also es
geht um die ja die großen sinnfragen die
menschen beschäftigen nicht tagein
tagaus bei den meisten menschen ist so
dass die durchs leben gehen solange
alles gut geht aber es gibt eben dann im
leben momente wo gewissen umbruch gibt
zwar plötzlich das ein oder andere
verloren geht
wo menschen sich dann wohl anfangen zu
fragen was ist jetzt für mich eigentlich
noch sinnvoll und das hat mich enorm
angesprochen als psychologin und vor
allem auch als mensch und da ich dann
eben die chance bekommen habe in der
organisation zu arbeiten
der mensch jetzt heißt unsere
organisation und der inhalt unserer
arbeit wir sind eigentlich eine art
humanistische pfarrer in gewisser
hinsicht wegbegleiter durch das leben
von beginn zu ende
von der geburt bis zum tod das hat mich
das hat mich fasziniert ihn wirklich so
ja von mensch zu mensch mit den
wesentlichen dingen des lebens zu
befassen
darüber reden wir gerne danach noch frau
not wie kam es zu ihrer tätigkeit sie
eine vielzahl von faktoren die dazu
geführt haben und ich behaupte gar nicht
dass ich den größten teil überhaupt
kenne sich mit eine rolle gespielt haben
biographische erlebnisse eigene krisen
schon in jugendjahren die die erfahrung
einfach nicht mehr weiter zu können
absolut verzweifelt zu sein und in
solche situationen menschen zu begegnen
die einem helfen und die das auf eine
solche art und weise tun dass es
wirklich hilfreich war
das heißt dass es mehr geholfen hat
sukzessive aus krisen herauszukommen
gestärkt herauszukommen
und ich denke diese erfahrung das hat
mich sehr geprägt und hat mich dann auch
aufmerksam werden lassen
ja wir haben die das gemacht was war das
denn genau was mitgeholfen hat in
situationen wo ich dachte da gibt es
überhaupt kein entrinnen mehr
und dass ich denke das was sich enorm
wichtig neben vielen anderen familiären
konstellationen brüche kann ich bin den
usa geboren bin und in die schweiz
gekommen
solche brüche also eine vielzahl von
erfahrungen die sich eine besondere
sensibilität geweckt haben für diese
fragen und das interessante sie wissen
auch aus der psychotherapie forschung
ein großteil psychotherapeutische
ansätze sind ja von sega von psychologen
psychotherapeuten entwickelt wurden
aufgrund auf der basis ihre eigenen
erfahrungen
und ich denke dasselbe gilt auch in
unserem beruf und auch jetzt für die
seelsorge und mich hat dann natürlich
auch interessiert die theoretische
reflexion dessen was wir machen ist weiß
man aus der forschung sind sie eben auch
seit 2000 zwölf professoren eben für
seelsorge und residieren auch den
weiterbildungslehrgang spilacek er ja
was ich ganz interessant fand an diesem
begriff und in der recherchen
vorgesprächen das den leuten eigentlich
gar nicht so klar ist was bild her ist
und auch je nachdem von wem an allen
text liest ist da quasi eine andere
definition da frage ich mich wissen die
experten denn nicht was sie tun es ist
so wie sonst in der schweizerischen
ärztezeitung erste zeitung wurde vor ein
paar jahren erschien ein artikel und da
stand es werden jetzt schon lehrstühle
eingerichtet für jetzt sogar noch nicht
mal weiß was es genau
aber so wird er sagt ja und deshalb auch
an es existiert eine vielzahl
unterschiedlicher konzepte von spot
repair genau auch wie von seelsorge auch
eine psychotherapie und sie
widersprechen sich zum teil aber was ist
es denn genau und sie sprechen etwas
wichtiges an was ist der unterschied
zwischen spiritual care und seelsorger
so wandten betreibt mannsbild verkehr
und wann betreibt man dann seelsorge
also das sind jetzt irgendwie 45 fragen
in einem ganz kurz es gibt im moment
gibt es zwei wenn ich jetzt die pole
nehme die eine seite die extreme sagt
also seelsorge ist eigentlich nichts
anderes als eine spezialisierte form von
swatch ok da ist aus der kasse joker ist
der oberbegriff und seelsorge ist das
auch etwas religiöses konfessionell
gebunden sicher irgendwo institutionell
gebunden ist und auf der gegenseite sind
diejenigen die sagen ja also was soll
dieses bildschirm das ist doch
eigentlich das was wir sehen sogar
eigentlich schon seit eh und je machen
ja also das sind zumal in dieser
bandbreite finden sie also quasi fast
alles gar nicht unterschreiben so von
dort ist die die
biologen und medizinern habt ihr ein
buch geschrieben hat darin auch
aufgelistet ich weiß wie viele
unterschiedlichen verstehens weisen im
moment an zu finden sind von spox wenn
sie mich jetzt fragen wann macht
jemanden sehe so gewannen macht jemand
türke
es ist schwer zu sagen am schluss würde
ich sagen es sind fließende übergänge
es kommt darauf wiederum an was versteht
jemand darunter und am schluss bestimmt
es dann auch die person die das
aufsuchen
aber dann wenn ich die frau isabel not
frage was ist für sie das bild verkehr
dann wenn sie mich einfach so wenn ich
das einfach auf den park begriffe
bringen sie wollen von mir jetzt nicht
mich wenn sie jetzt nicht ich fühle mich
einfach wirklich dazu sagen es gibt
diese ganze bankeinlagen wenn sie mich
persönlich fragen sage ich ihm
es ist der von der ich bin ursprünglich
auch historie kriegen mich interessieren
natürlich die geschichtlichen
entwicklungen hat sich aus der
hospizbewegung den 60er jahren des
letzten jahrhunderts entwickelt
insbesondere aus der palliativpflege von
dem er ist es primär ein medizinisches
setting aus dem brk kam natürlich
insbesondere auch aus dem palliativ care
gedanken
es füge hier auch sogleich an es war
auch ein kritisches konzept gegenüber
eine medizin die biologistische
menschenbild pflegt den körper fixiert
war und man also es ist alles anders die
versucht hatten den griechen ihren
turnieren die gesucht hat wird die die
verschiedenen bedürfnisse von menschen
in den blick zu dem unter anderem eben
auch spirituelle bedürfnisse was
vergessen geht sie sitzt wenn sie auch
noch mal nicht frage dass das auch
häufiger auch sehr stark christlich
geprägt ist schon der begriff
es wird so getan als wäre das etwas
jenseits des christlichen ich meine
schon notbetrieb spiritualität ist ja
sowas von christlich konnotiert und
geprägt dass das spannende daran eben an
dem begriff der spiritualität
da würd mich dann auch ihre meinung
interessieren ist dass er eben in den
letzten jahren unglaublich eineinhalb
quasi um ihn geworden ist man sieht auch
im wissenschaftlichen publikationen wie
der seit den letzten etwa 20 jahren
wirklich fahrt aufgenommen haben wir
haben hier auch eine grafik mitgenommen
wo man das sieht es steigt seit 2012
würde ich sagen in etwa bis jetzt heute
das natürlich die die grafik noch nicht
fertig aber man sieht steigt
kontinuierlich an
deswegen wurde denn die spiritualität so
wichtig ich kann natürlich da auch nur
vermutungen dazu anstellen ich denke ist
es ein basis bedürfnis des menschen
jedweder religiöser oder
weltanschaulicher überzeugungen um sich
im sinn zu finden ihnen sind zu erfüllen
und ich denke unabhängig von der eigenen
werte überzeugung und so weiter ist es
so dass die fertig suche nach sind das
ist dass es den menschen eigen und das
ist humanisten haben ja den ruf dass sie
sehr rational sind und alles erklären
können wollen ich persönlich ich bin
selber humanisten und humanistische
beraterin
ich finde das auch interessant um alles
zu untersuchen
ich untersuche auch gerne selbst und
akzeptieren nicht irgendwelche festen
überzeugung die jemand anders mir an
reichen sie sind nicht dogmatisch ich
bin nicht dogmatisch aber das ist für
mich gerade weil ich von meiner praxis
arbeit heraus es ist für mich nicht
wichtig alles erklären zu können es ist
einfach auch wichtig dass ich mich als
mensch berühren lassen kann dass ich
mich das mich dinge erschüttern das also
dass und das einfach was ist für mich
spiritualität es ist für mich eine fast
transzendente erfahrung die meines
erachtens auch möglich ist wenn man
selber nicht an einen gott glaubt es ist
und woran also wo findet dann diese
spirituelle erfahrung statt unter
anderem sehr intensiven kontakt von
mensch zu mensch wenn man den menschen
begegnen das ist gerade denke ich in
unserer arbeit bei uns beiden soll dabei
jedweder spiritual care oder seelsorger
also das sind verschiedenen namen aber
worum geht es eigentlich in unserer
arbeit
den menschen nahe sein in sehr schwierig
momenten seines lebens und wegbegleiter
sein also gefühle von ohnmacht und
machtlosigkeit aushalten und zusammen
gucken was wo liegt die kraft des
anderen um mit diesen schwierigkeiten
doch umzugehen und stand zu halten also
sagt jetzt dann auch in gewisser
hinsicht um resilienz widerstandskraft
kommt er also spiritualität was ist das
das es so dieser diese fast
transzendenten moment wo man dem anderen
so nahe ist und in seiner verletzbarkeit
verwundbarkeit und in dem was ihm oder
ihr wirklich wichtig ist dann sagen sie
also es ist gewissermaßen eine
menschliche konstante die unabhängig
davon ob jemand irgendwie einen
metaphysischen bezug hat oder nicht beim
menschen vorkommt also sie quasi lösen
das jetzt klar auch von der religion da
interessiert mich natürlich jetzt ihre
meinung
deswegen auch das so wichtig wurde jetzt
wie man gesehen hat das ist ja wirklich
erstaunlich ja das hat das hat natürlich
auch hier wieder sehr unterschiedliche
gründe ganz sicher ist in einer
multireligiösen weltanschaulich pluralen
welt ist es einfacher zu sagen ich bin
spirituell also ich bin religiös und es
gibt eine vielzahl von untersuchungen
die auch zeigen was menschen mit diesem
begriff notieren was sie eigentlich
damit mein und da kommen dann bei
spiritualität kommen begriffe wie natur
geist sind werden bei religion kommen
dogma kirche gottesdienst in institution
und das führt dann ein bisschen dazu
dass religion für alles herhalten muss
für das verfasste institutionalisierte
und spiritualität ist quasi dann das
gute das was mit freiheit verbunden ist
und das ist der grund wieso wir jetzt
dieses bild ok ausbildung aufgegleist
haben wir wie gesagt hat im moment
wir haben ja eigentlich in einer langen
langen geschichte der theologischen
auseinandersetzung herausgefunden dass
religion stets ambivalent ist es gibt
keine religion an sich die gut wert oder
die schlechte und dasselbe gilt für die
spiele
es gibt keine spiritualität und sich wir
haben auch da dieselben phänomen es gibt
spiritualität formen die menschen krank
machen können die sie in die
abhängigkeit führen können genauso wie
beim ganzen thema religion
deshalb ist es so wichtig jetzt auch mit
religions- psychologischer perspektive
diese begriffe und insbesondere dann die
bestimmten aus formen wie wird die
spiritualität konkret gelebt wie wird
religiosität gelebt auch da es ist ja
eine so enorme spannweite innerhalb der
fan religionen oder wenn jemand
muslimisch ist heißt das noch lange
nicht dass sie alle dasselbe
praktizieren oder da gibt es eine solche
diversität wie christentum ja sowieso
man muss vielleicht anmerken sie sind ja
auch noch religion psychologin nebst
theologin also haben sie ganz ihr
themenfeld 2000 sie arbeiten eben seit
jahren in belgien als humanistische
beraterin
sie bieten das heißt letztlich bieten
religionsfreie gespräche an
auf welche werte berufen sie sich denn
da konkret ich persönlich in meiner
haltung den anderen gegenüber als mensch
ich berufe mich auf die humanistischen
werte und was ist darin für mich zentral
das ist dass der mensch selbst
verantwortlich ist als er tapfer und
träger seine eigenen werte
es gibt im prinzip keine übergeordnete
instanz die mir sagt was objekt eine
objektive in anführungszeichen gut oder
schlecht ist und es ist sehr wichtig die
dinge immer wieder erneut in frage zu
stellen also die die frau das prinzip
der freien untersuchungen also teils
sachverhalte in frage zu stellen meine
haltung den dingen der welt anderen
gegenüber in frage zu stellen also das
ist ich meine grundwerte sind
humanistisch wobei es so ist das im
prinzip bei mir alle menschen willkommen
sind und ich erlebe dass die meisten die
den weg zu mir finden beziehungsweise
dann die ich dann besuche im krankenhaus
im altersheim
eine psychiatrie das sind menschen die
die meisten sind zumindest nicht
kirchlich nicht gläubig da bin ich sehr
vorsichtig weil ich finde ich stehe
übrigens persönlich als romanistin ich
stehe gläubigen menschen nicht ablehnend
gegenüber ich finde das fürchterlich
arrogant ich finde es ist wichtig dass
es einfach alles gleichwertig
nebeneinander bestehen darf für mich die
humanistischen werte im prinzip sind
interessen main es ist mein
ausgangspunkt und ich begegne dem
anderen von mensch zu mensch und es
passiert durchaus auch das auch
religiöse zum teil gläubige menschen
sich an mich wenden vor allem dann wenn
es um themen geht wo sie davon ausgehen
dass sie sich in kirchlichen kreisen
oder religiösen damit einem religiösen
gesprächspartner womöglich in der tabus
fähre befinden wie zb eben wie gehe ich
um mit umgewöhnen unerwünschte
schwangerschaft wie gehe ich um mit dem
wunsch nach sterbehilfe uns so weiter
also das sind das sind themen wo ich
merke dass in der wahrnehmung dass
andere das ich als humanistische
beraterin dass sie das gefühl haben das
was er auch seine annahme natürlich es
gibt auch fantastische kirchliche oder
christliche seelsorge die genauso offen
und vorurteilsfrei zu hören können die
ich das kann aber in der wahrnehmung der
menschen die sich an mich wenden ist es
das spielt das oft eine rolle sie denken
aber mit einer humanistischen beraterin
mit der sonne sicher stern
sie sprechen jetzt das schon ein
bisschen an was mich natürlich
interessiert und auch die zuschauer
interessiert für menschen in ihrer rolle
gibt es geschichten die sie ganz
besonders bewegt haben die sie teilen
dürfen
es gibt eine fülle an begegnungen und
und menschen die mich die mich
beschäftigt haben und die mir ab und zu
wieder in den sinn kommen jetzt auch
wenn ich jetzt seit mehreren jahren
wirklich in der ausbildung tätig bin es
gibt personen die mir noch nach jahren
ich sage jetzt mal vielleicht drei vier
mal pro jahr anrufen und da geht es
schlecht und nur darum eine kurze
kontaktaufnahme
die wollen nicht dass ich ihnen einen
termin anbieten oder mit ihnen zum
kaffee episoden es reicht einfach
schnell miteinander im kontakt stehen
und das ist das was mich so fasziniert
an diese niederschwellig kite der
seelsorge dass sie auch da ist für
menschen die aus einer
psychotherapeutischen perspektive
chancenlos sind aufgegeben wurde erst
recht als eine psychiatrischen
perspektive die die nicht die können
sich mehr da wenn sie nicht mehr an sich
arbeiten wollen oder nicht können das
ist nicht die voraussetzung 7 dürfen
genau so bleiben wie sie sind und es
genügt in diese kurze kontaktaufnahme
mehr wäre für sie wahrscheinlich gar
nicht auszuhalten und das ist das schöne
und der seelsorge dass sie das geben
kann
ich stimme zu dass für mich und das sehr
treffend formuliert und sehr interessant
dass es ja und das ist auch was ich zu
erklären versuchte ein aspekt der
spiritualität ist für mich ebenso dieses
intense momente das kontakt dass ich ein
mensch zu mensch und das braucht
tatsächlich nicht lange zu dauern
in meinem empfinden nach ist das was ich
vor allem bieten kann was ich so
wertvoll finde und wo ich auch das
feedback bekommen von dem anderen oder
der anderen dass das wertvoll ist dass
der andere bei mir mensch sein darf dass
es nicht darum geht zu diagnostizieren
was ist ein krankheitsbild das ist eine
störung sondern dass der andere einfach
gefühl haben kann hier darf ich einfach
sein der ich bin hier darf ich ganz
mensch sein hier gilt mein menschsein im
vordergrund und das ist auch so dass in
unserer arbeit geht es eigentlich nicht
so sehr um das erreichen von bestimmten
zielen innerhalb eines bestimmten
zeitraums natürlich darf was erreicht
werden und sehen wir menschen
unglaublich evaluieren oft sehen dass
die menschen wachsen und sich
weiterentwickeln und stärker werden
aber es ist bei uns keine prämisse dass
das passieren muss bei uns geht es
eigentlich um akzeptanz es geht darum
dass es ja oft schwierige situationen
das dass es einfach das design dürfen
was es in erster linie dass sie nicht
gelöst werden müssen dass es dass der
andere nicht das gefühl hat ich bin
abnormal weil ich damit nicht nicht so
gut umgehen kann der andere darf darf
sich darf darf damit schwierigkeiten
haben der andere darf sein wie er ist in
dem moment und das ist ja 70 mir bei
sojasoße das finde ich dass das finde
ich dass das wertvolle der mensch als
ganzes ohne dass ich ihn beurteilen
ich wollte eben genau darauf ansprechen
weil die frauen und not hat ja sie haben
das zwar nicht ganz ausgeführt aber wie
mir scheint es ist doch so dass das bild
wirkt er genauso wie die
palliativmedizin sich quasi auf eine auf
diese vier ebenen des menschen beziehen
ebene es ist ja er ist eben nicht nur
körper oder nicht nur geist oder oder
psyche sondern eben über das ist etwas
über das was ihnen quasi das seelische
oder spirituelle quasi mit einbezieht
und da frage ich mich inwiefern haben
auch sie als humanist in ein politisches
menschenbild oder eben fehlt da etwas
das ist quasi eine kritische rückfrage
in bezug auf den holistischen begriff
des menschen es ist natürlich in
atheistischen kreisen großer
diskussionspunkt die seele gibt es sie
oder gibt es nichts
die hardcore atheisten am die neigung zu
sagen seele ist ein christlich besetzter
begriff ich persönlich sehe den begriff
der seele er in so definition die psyche
und in der hinsicht habe ich damit kein
problem also ist für mich der mensch
etwas was jeder mensch ist ein ganzes
aus körper seele geist und die partie
die verschiedenen teile auch nicht
voneinander trennen wollen sondern das
ist einfach dass es eine wechselwirkung
zwischen all den teilen also es ist
ich persönlich habe kein problem mit dem
begriff der sehen
aber finde es natürlich auch wichtig
dass deutlich ist dass das noch aus der
seele ein weiterer begriff ist als eben
nur so wie es in den kirchlichen kreisen
definiert wird
das werden wir jetzt ein bisschen zu eng
kirchliche das weiß ich nicht genau weiß
welche sie damit genau meinen
wichtigkeit mit wenn sie sagen
körper geist seele ich meine es gibt
eine solche vielzahl unterschiedlicher
konzepte und auch das was sie hier
gebracht haben hat natürlich einen
klaren traditionsstrecke
wir haben ja insbesondere zwei
traditionsstrecke in der ganzen seelen
diskussion ein griechisch antiken und
den auf denen sie jedem die seelsorge
beruf ist dieser wert legt auf dieses
wurzel und das ist halt schon die
hebräische anthropologie es gibt kein
direktes adäquaten begriff im
hebräischen dafür aber in der günter
wurde ja der begriff nachteil das ist
die seele der jugend der schlund die
kehle der atem der rachen also diese
teil hier die empfänglichkeit des
menschen da wo wir aufnehmen wo wir luft
aufnehmen
das wird dann quasi zum mensch selbst
zum leben selbst und das unter der
mensch ist die seele qual mensch ist das
ist in seiner ganzen empfänglichkeit und
das wurde dann übersetzt mit psyche in
der seb günther und dann halt mit seele
und es hat die griechische ausgabe muss
man vielleicht hat sie die griechische
ausgabe der das des alten testaments und
diese begriffe nash umfasst also den
menschen als ganzes und die seelsorge
bezieht sich zurück auf dieses
menschenbild dieses wirklich umfassende
der menschen seine vitalität der punkt
ist dass bei diesem hebräischen denken
es keine tradition vorstellbar da
irgendwie körper zu trennen von vernunft
und von sales das sind keine qualität
high dort das gehört zusammen
der mensch ist nach der mensch ist zähle
er hat keine seele
also er ist ist und dass deshalb ist
diese begriffe uns
ich bin ihm sehr dankbar so wie sie
beschrieben haben das ist also das darf
also und das fast erleuchtend videos
kann man da wirklich kann mich damit für
erfolg kommen ist ja da dass wir uns
dafür hab ich noch kurz zurück war das
nicht doch wunderbar sie sagen
religionslos religions- lose gespräch
habe ich das richtig ja ich glaube das
waren begriffen dass sie genauer gesagt
haben wenig oder große gleiche es ist
natürlich da ich ja mich auf die
humanistischen werte beziehen die ja zu
einem ganz großen teil wenn man guckt
einen verschiedenen weltanschauungen und
religionen um welche werte geht es
eigentlich
ich lehne mich zurück ich war zufällig
mal im neanderthal museum im neandertal
in deutschland das gibt es also wirklich
das neandertal das ein ganz tolles
museum und das geht in der spirale in
dem gang nach oben und da entlang sind
so die verschiedenen aus den
verschiedensten kulturen und religionen
und weltanschauungen sind so die
zentralen werte zusammengefasst und dass
die stehen so gleichberechtigt
nebeneinander und da fällt einerseits
schön auf wo so gewisse spezifische
unterschiede sind aber was mindestens
genauso auffällt ist dass es eine ganz
große gemeinsame basis gibt und die
humanistischen werte was da natürlich wo
daten die die schwerpunkt dass sie
natürlich in den verschiedenen
weltanschauungen etwas anders und was er
noch immer beim humanismus stark im
vordergrund steht ist autonomie und
selbstbestimmung natürlich immer in
verbundenheit mit dem anderen menschen
meine autonomie oder freiheit geht
genauso weiter
bis 7 die freiheit das anderen in
bedrängnis genau aber jedenfalls die
selbstbestimmung ist sehr sehr wichtig
immer also in meiner tätigkeit oder in
also in meinen humanistischen werte
hintergrund es ist allerdings natürlich
so ich beziehe mich nicht auf einen gott
also religionslos und der begriff swerts
nicht einer der mir direkt ein viele
wenn mich jemand fragt was machst du
eigentlich will ich nicht sagen ich
mache religions- lose gespräche aber ich
würde möglicherweise ich würde denke ich
so umschreiben ich bin
wegbegleiterin durchs leben vom anfang
bis zum ende von der geburt bis zum tod
ich bin da in den wichtigen momenten des
lebens die für den anderen wirklich die
den anderen berühren und muss entweder
was zu feiern gibt zwar in berge machen
wir auch feiern zur wichtigen
lebensmomente also muss man da noch kurz
einführen in belgien ist es ja noch
speziell in bezug auf die religion
situation also es ist zwar ein
katholisches land und stark katholisch
geprägt dabei soweit ich weiß sind die
menschen die eben quasi religions-
ungebunden sind nicht eben der kirche
angehören fast die hälfte der
gesellschaft machen die aus und insofern
dass man ein bisschen die relation hat
das ist das gut dass sie das tatsächlich
noch hinzufügen das ist so ja denn das
ist spiegelt sich auch wider in der
gesetzgebung in der tatsache dass es
meine art der tätigkeit seit über 30
jahren gibt mittlerweile es ist genau
das sei das einfach eben das hat sich so
in berlin entwickelt und das hat eben
einen rahmen geschaffen
innerhalb dessen humanistische beratung
möglich ist und ich persönlich bin sehr
dankbar für nicht nur weil ich meinen
beruf selber sehr gern macht sondern
weil ich einfach davon ausgehe
ich habe vorhin schon gesagt ich finde
die verschiedensten weltanschauungen
sind gleichberechtigt und ich finde das
sehr wichtig dass man miteinander ins
gespräch kommt ich habe auch keinerlei
feindbilder ich mein hintergrund ist
selbst meine eltern sind evangelisch
nicht verteilt
aber ich finde ich finde das einfach
wichtig deutlich zu machen wie ich
selber im leben stehe ich anderen
weltanschauungen und religionen
gegenüber steht dass es für mich keine
anti haltung ist sondern ein ja im
nebeneinander bestehen einer fruchtbar
ergänzen
spannenden dialog sich einsperren dialog
gegeben
ich möchte gerne aber ich möchte gerne
hier etwas weiter fahren sie haben
sofort selber angesprochen die resilienz
es ist ja so dass mit krisensituationen
das wissen sie besser als ich nicht
jeder mensch auf dieselbe weise umgeht
eben gewisse menschen zerbrechen daran
und bei anderen staunt man wie stark sie
sind wir haben hier ein beispiel von
einer besonders starken person
diese frau hat mich sehr berührt eben in
ihrer widerstandsfähigkeit gegen die
schicksalsschläge eben was man resilienz
nennt inwiefern hat residenz auch in
ihrer arbeit jeweils reingespielt oder
brasilien resilienz training für
patienten oder klienten beeindruckt
einen jahr zutiefst ich finde es ist ja
wirklich möchte man sagen ist ein wunder
dass ein mensch wie acht jahre damals
diese diese enormen kräfte entwickelt
und wie sie da gesagt weit weit und dann
gab es kein halten mehr
ich denke es geht darum in der seelsorge
in speed ok in gesprächen zu schauen wo
können menschen solche ressourcen
aktivieren und wo können sie etwas so
aktivieren dass sie in die kraft gibt
jetzt weiter zu fahren
also das ist absolut grundlegend und ich
denke der haut punkt ist dass wir sehen
das alles wirklich auf die persönliche
einschätzung darauf ankommt hätte diese
person die einschätzung gehabt mein
leben ist jetzt zu ende und so kann kein
mensch leben
dann wäre mit aller wahrscheinlichkeit
dass bedeutend schwieriger gewesen als
mit dieser einstellung ich habe den
traum ich will da wieder ein ich will
wieder spielen ich will mich ins leben
werfen als eigentlich umso spezieller
als so junges kind wo man so viel
unterwegs ist und dann explizit die
beine fehlen sorgen machen sie so was
wie resilienz training
nicht gezählt also ist es nicht so dass
ich den gegenwert zu mir kommen sagt wir
machen jetzt resilienz training aber das
ist das schon also was passiert in den
gesprächen hat damit zu tun ich versuche
zu explorieren wo die inneren kräfte das
analoge gegen genauso
ich habe als berater und ich denke kein
guter seelsorger des humanismus oder
nicht wir haben keine standard antworten
zu beten macht s oder das dann wird
schon gut
wir untersuchen gemeinsam mit dem
anderen wo die kräfte liegen wird und
was sie sagen die einschätzung ist das a
und o ich stimme dem zu und was wir oft
wo wir helfen können ist dass wir die
situation versuchen aus einem anderen
blickwinkel zu belangen
also dass wir dem anderen nahe genug
sind dass das gefühl hat da ist eine
vertrauensperson an meiner seite dem die
mich also die die bäume ist dies das
haben wir die situation aushält und dass
ich trotzdem weit genug weg bin
um auch einen anderen blickwinkel ein
emotionen und daneben dem anderen auch
ja zu helfen irgendwie die eigene
einschätzung der situation zu ändern und
die eigenen kräfte zu entdecken als
vieler menschen
ich fand die frau auch unglaublich
beeindruckend dabei ist es ja auch so
speziell man sieht wirklich empfehlen
wie stark sie erleben leben kann sie ja
sogar zwei kinder
aber es ist erschreckend innerhalb von
irgendwie 30 jahre später oder so
innerhalb von einer woche sterben die
zwei engsten personen von ihr und dann
plötzlich spricht sie über ihre gefühle
und da merkt man was was in ihr vorgeht
sie spricht er hier sogar von
suizidgedanken ich fand das
gewissermaßen erstaunlich dass diese
frau die zuvor so stark war und etwas
durchlebt hat dass viele sich überhaupt
nicht vorstellen können dann durch diese
schicksalsschläge so aus der bahn
geworfen wird
dahinter steht die vorstellung wir sein
wie konstant wir sind wir sind wie sie
nicht stabil gewesen
je nach situation je nach lebensphase je
nach ganz vielen verschiedenen aspekten
können wir auch unterschiedlich
reagieren
von daher finde ich es sehr plausibel
dass eine person unterschiedlich stark
stark in anführungszeichen auch das ist
eine enorme stärke dass diese gefühle
kommen können das auch gefühle wie
suizidalität dass es auch bestandteil
ist eine ganz vehementen reaktion auf
einen solchen norden schicksal einer
akuten krise quasi eine gesunde reaktion
sagen sie fast schon völlig im bereich
des menschlich normale und an führung
ist nicht selbstverständlich
also das ist überhaupt kein das kann man
nicht bewerten als irgendwie
die person sei jetzt da nicht stark nein
es zeichnet ja auch menschen aus dass
sie das durch leben können die frage ist
wie sieht das aus nach ein paar monaten
das ist ja dann die entscheidende frage
dass als reaktion ist das sehr
verständlich
ich möchte einen schritt weiter gehen
oder vielleicht das quasi auch mit dem
vorhergehenden noch verbinden
in bezug auf das verhältnis jetzt auch
von humanistischer beratung und switche
der seelsorge weil man könnte eben auch
sagen es gibt ja offenkundig sie haben
dasselbe zur forschung angesprochenen
auf den bezug auf die spiritualität
einen wandeln bezug eben auf die
relevanz von institutionelle
institutionalisierter religion was man
ihnen auch in belgien sehr gut zieht und
da könnte man ja fragen ist dann die
humanistische beratung eben nicht so was
wie das wirkliche zukunftsmodell von
seelsorge ja da bin also ich bin zwar um
eine schöne berater ich mache meinen
beruf sehr gern und ich hoffe auch dass
er bis in die weitere zukunft bestehen
bleibt aber ich fände es eigentlich
immer arroganz wenn irgend eine
bestimmte ausrichtung der seelsorge ob
sie jetzt religiös oder humanistisch ist
für sich beanspruchen würde ich bin das
einzig wahre genau aber die frage ist ja
würde es vielleicht nicht als antwort
aus der gesellschaft heraus kommen das
ist natürlich auch eine spannende frage
für die religions- psychologie also ich
kenne die humanistische beratung
insbesondere aus dem us amerikanischen
kontext und mädchen auch dort engagiert
ist das richtig ich habe ich wollte im
rahmen von forschungsprojekten torten
tja und was mir dort ausgezeichnet
gefällt ist ja die zusammenarbeit und
wenn wir ja immer wieder versuchen
müssen von den personen auszudenken die
seelsorge oder beratung suchen das sind
ja dass die müssen wir uns die kriterien
geben dann finde ich von diesen personen
aus gesehen ist es doch wunderbar gibt
es ein vielfältiges angebot
das heißt ich darf nicht von mir aus
denken und sagen ein es gibt nur die
gesetzliche oder sorgen von von diesen
personen ausgedacht ist je nach
situation kann eine andere person mit
einem anderen hintergrund genau diese
person
das richtige gehen und unsere aufgabe
ist zu schauen dass die vielfalt
möglichst gerader und insgesamt in einer
solchen multireligiösen nochmals
weltanschaulich pluralen gesellschaft
genau unter bringen sie mich zum
nächsten punkte nämlich in der schweiz
und sie waren da quasi auch zu besuch
gibt es ja eben auch die freidenker und
der präsident der freidenker andreas
korea co hat ja so was wie die wohl
sorge quasi gefordert was eben staatlich
finanziert wie er jetzt als kompliment
zu religiös geprägten seelsorge und man
muss ja schon wissen in der schweiz in
mindestens ein nicht mindestens sondern
sind genau etwa ein viertel der
bevölkerung konfessionslos das heißt
natürlich nicht dass die religionslos
sind aber zumindest sind sie
konfessionslos heißt das dass ihre
seelsorger des bildschirm kleben für die
atheisten nicht genügt
der gedankengang werden wir jetzt etwas
zu schnell weil weil die saison hat ja
den anspruch dass sie ist ja so in die
welt getreten sage ich mal mit dem
anspruch dass sie für alle da sein soll
und sie hatte auch explizit konzept
entwickelt die eben nicht einfach nur
spezifisch für die eigenen
kirchenmitglieder sind sollten wirklich
die note oder otto oder die bedürfnisse
aller anspricht jetzt was freidenker
anbelangt wir stehen ja auch in
gesprächen das alles wunderbar ich
glaube nicht dass ein viertel der
schweizer bevölkerung jetzt freidenker
sind im sinne wie es frei denkt geht
selber verstehen da bin ich überzeugt
dass das nicht so ist der punkt wäre für
mich wie sieht die ausbildung nicht ich
würde einfach nicht unterschätzen dass
das menschen sind diesen einer
verletzlichen situation und sie bringen
beratungs personen sehen sollten dann
sehr viel vertrauen entgegen
und ich möchte und ich denke dass auch
unsere aufgabe dass wir schauen alles
getan wird dass die personen die dann
staatlicherseits dem zugang erhalten zu
diesen person wirklich vertrauenswürdig
sind und das heißt gut ausgebildet
seriös ausgebildet und wirklich wissen
was sie da tun und da gehören gerade im
existenziellen bereich gehört hat schon
ziemlich viel dazu vorsichtig umzugehen
in der weil sie und weil sie befürchten
dass es da auch missbräuche eben geben
kann so ist es ja aber ich möchte da
trotzdem ganz kurz noch drauf eingehen
oder das erwidern weil sie sagen sie ist
die seelsorge ist zwar für alle das
problem ist nur wenn diese alle in
teilen von diesen tagen ihr aber die
wollen dieses organ nicht in dieser form
das ist ja eigentlich letztlich das was
die freidenker sagen schön und gut seid
ihr für alle aber wir wollen nicht zu
diesen allen gehören und das
unterstützen sie ja dass es dieses
gesprächsangebot und da möchte ich euch
doch zurückkommen auf das was sie vorher
gesagt haben was ich sehr schön
formuliert haben es ist die vielfalt die
wichtig ist es eben gleichberechtigt
verschiedene angebote nebeneinander
gehen weil ich denke sie gehen somit mit
den menschen um das im prinzip dass es
für alle da sein kann
genauso gilt das auch für mich ich bin
ja also das ist ja vorher auch schon
ausgeführt habe ich bin nicht nur für
die nichtreligiösen oder für die nicht
konfessionell gebunden da sondern für
alle im prinzip aber so das haben sie
sehr schön formuliert eigentlich ist das
wichtigste dass wir vom anderen
ausdenken und die bedürfnisse es gibt
also wie viel prozent das sind dann
möchte ich mich überhaupt nicht darauf
festlegen ob das jetzt ein viertel der
bevölkerung des weniger oder mehr es
gibt jedenfalls doch beträchtlich viele
menschen die wohl das bedürfnis haben
dass sie selber entscheiden können wenn
ich mich jetzt an so einen seelsorger so
ein oder der humoristische beratung
es ist einfach ich denke es wäre eine
enorme bereicherung ein enormer reichtum
wenn es eben diese vans verschiedenen
der derjenige der in existenzieller not
ist die möglichkeit hat sich selbst
entscheiden an wen er oder sie sich
wenden kann
das wäre wichtig und ich denke das ist
vor allem den freidenkern auch ein
anliegen nicht so sehr um sich selbst zu
profilieren hoher wir sind toll und wir
machen das jetzt sondern einfach so ich
denke im moment sehen sie ihre aufgabe
darin dafür zu sorgen dass es dass es in
der zukunft diese möglichkeit gibt wohl
sorge sie haben den begriff hantiert das
war auf der suche nach einem
nach einem namen war das so einer der
ersten fälle
ich habe mich gestern noch mit zwei
menschen von den freidenkern unterhalten
und sie haben gesagt für uns wäre es
schön wenn du das auch benennen könnte
ist als humanistische gesprächsangeboten
damit kann ich mich sehr gut
identifizieren und im endeffekt es ist
natürlich wichtig dass das das ganze
einen namen erhält oder später aber das
allerwichtigste ist denke ich dass der
bevölkerung vor allem deutlich wird was
beinhalten kann und dann ja der name ist
nicht unwichtig aber es ist nicht das
wichtigste wichtigstes der inhalt ganz
gemäß wichtig zu sagen dass sie so ist
ein freiwilliges angebot
das ist absolut zentral und studien
zeigen dass das die seelsorge sehr
beliebt ist und sehr gut ankommt in den
verschiedenen institutionen das uns sehr
wichtig so ist es in ergänzung zu
anderen berufssparten das ist so also
ich sehe mich auch nicht als die also
würde ich sagen dass das ein psychologe
macht oder ein sozialarbeiter oder einen
arzt oder also gerade berufssparten
haben ihren eigenen wert das schöne ist
eigentlich das liegt in der ergänzung
generell ich möchte der einhalten weil
sie haben mir im vorgespräch auch gesagt
dass für sie in der seelsorge immer
etwas drittes mitbürger so sind sie und
die gesprächs person und es wirkt etwas
drittes mit und ich habe mich dann
gefragt wie stark verbreitet sind
tatsächlich so klassisch
materialistische sichtweisen also wo es
quasi nur die körperliche ebene gibt
nichts was quasi den menschen selber als
materie übersteigt bei sterbenden das
finde ich wirklich sehr interessant auch
in bezug jetzt auf diese auf diese
forderung der wohl sorge wie verbreitet
ist dass ich denke es werden
interessante phase im leben benannt bei
sterbenden denke dass jemand der in
seiner letzten lebensphase ist noch mal
sehr stark so die eigenen werte sehr
stark in den vordergrund genommen
das ist auch bei humanistisch orientiert
menschen so und
das interessant ist dann eigentlich dass
ich da bin um noch mal zu gucken was ist
dem oder der anderen eigentlich wirklich
wichtig und ich denke da geht es in
jedweder form der seelsorge drum also es
ist bei gläubigen menschen denke ich
werden auch noch mal die die eigenen
glaubens begriffe gegen schlicht
gehalten ist also ich denke die meisten
gläubigen haben auch ihre momente des
zweifels ist wichtig ist einfach dass
man als seelsorger den raum und die zeit
und die möglichkeit bietet zusammen mit
einem anderen zu untersuchen was ist mir
wichtig was bedeutet mir was wohl ich
das gibt mir kraft und ja also bei
humanistisch orientierten menschen sind
es eben im allgemeinen die dirty die
humanistischen werte also die zum teil
überlappen mit so sich überschneiden mit
den werten den anderen welt anschauen
aber das ist also es ist ja so ist es
aber das ist für mich beantwortet die
frage noch nicht wie verbreitet jetzt
diese eben ganz rein materialistische
sichtweise ist eben sie sagen das
spezifisch eben in diesem
lebensabschnitt von bei sterbenden und
ich spreche das natürlich bewusst da an
weil man kennt das ja auch dass in
diesen situationen sie haben dasselbe
erwähnt personen noch mal ihre werte
überdenken denn religiöse personen haben
sie mir auch noch betont im volk spricht
teilweise sogar speziell leiden weil sie
habe dann entweder mit dem glauben oder
mit gewissen dogmen die quasi
weitergereicht werden in der religion
was sagen sie dazu
würden sie sagen wie verbreitet ist dass
ich glaube jetzt keine empirische studie
irgendwie gerade parat was was was das
anbelangt aber es ist sicher dass die
die religiosität die spiritualität die
eine person während ihres lebens
praktiziert hat oder die auffassung
deine person sicher dann auch in der
letzten phase ihres lebens prägen seine
und wenn
ist das deshalb ist es ja auch so
wichtig auch in der theologie zu schauen
und auch in der beratung natürlich auch
was sind das lebens förderliche
vorstellung sind das lebenslängliche
vorstellen sind das oder sind das solche
die menschen klein machen unabhängig
machen und das sind ja die die
knackpunkte an denen es dann zu arbeiten
gibt gibt es da noch ein bisschen
spielraum der jetzt wichtig werden
könnte dieser letzten phase
das sind so themen es gibt ja auch
studien die die genesung verbinden mit
der religiosität oder eben spiritualität
einer person also wo man sagt dass die
person die eben quasi diesen rückhalt
hat eine bessere oder schnellere
genesung also hätte da gibt es eine
vielzahl an die zeigen dass personen die
frau tot sind die religiöse
vorstellungen haben aus parat haben die
religiös spirituellen leben dass die wir
sprechen dann von der salutogenese aus
das ist gesundheitsfördernd das hilft
bei dem kolping mechanismen das heißt
religion konnte man kann besser damit um
gewaltige ja weil man sehen und
orientierung verschiedene geschichten
und bilder und vorstellungswelten parat
hat die einen hilfreich sein können in
der deutung der eigenen situation also
dass das ist glaube ich sehe nicht ich
glaube das ist sehr gut untersucht und
auch sehr spannend wobei eben und das
möchte ich schon sagen auch die andere
seite es gibt natürlich eine vielzahl
von von vorstellungen die menschen dann
auch knechten können ja genau
aber was ich daran schon spannend finde
ich möchte das auch kritisch reflektiert
wie sie arbeiten ja aus diesen gründen
auch mit mit medizinischen fakultät
zusammen also und deswegen ist das bild
verkehr sicher auch anerkannt im bereich
der medizin aber man könnte ja auch
sagen das ist eine pervertierung der
spiritualität wenn sie eben für diesen
evaluieren beitrag der medizin quasi
ausgenutzt wird wir kennen diese
bewegung in mein volles bewegungen zb
diverse große unternehmen bieten ihren
ihren mitarbeitern meditationskurs an
über
mittag und danach sind sie weniger krank
sie arbeiten besser konzentrierter
weniger fällt fehler
also man könnte es auch so sehen das ist
meine große kritik und der geschichte
die die ganze bezirke sowie palliativ
care ist die ursprünglich aus einem
einem kritischen impetus entstanden sie
wollten die die medizin vielleicht nicht
gerade revolutionär aber fast und was
jetzt geschehen ist je mehr sich die
medizin die diese thematik angenommen
hat desto mehr wie die spiritualität
medikalisierung also anstatt dass es zu
einer veränderung rückkopplungseffekte
in speziellen gekommen wäre sprechen wir
umgekehrt sich von special
dieses bild fridman all diese
fachbegriffe die eigentlich also einen
ganz anderen kontext stammen werden nun
in diesen spiritualität zusammenhang
eingefügt und und dass sie uns schon in
welche richtung das es läuft und dass
das gefällt mir nicht und da bin ich
wirklich sehr sehr kritisch
ich möchte da einfach ganz kurz zurück
fragen die kritik an der medizin ist
jene dass der mensch quasi einfach nur
eindimensional gesehen wird und einfach
auch diese diese ökonomisierung und und
das alles immer wieder so rational
erläutert werden also das unverfügbare
das was doch ja gerade wenn menschen
krank sind viel viel bedrängender und
viele offensichtliche da ist dass das
das wird versucht irgendwie rote zu
drücken und portugal seelsorge
humanistische beratung das sind ja alles
versuche irgendwie dieses zu werden zu
sagen doch da gibt es der mensch ist
letztlich doch auch irgendwie ein
geheimnis ich hoffe sie würden also da
gibt es auch ganz viele aspekte die
können wir nicht messen und evaluieren
und so weiter und dies die diese diese
perspektiven müssen evivo lebendig
bleiben sonst werden wir menschen nicht
gerecht
[Musik]
jetzt möchte ich da noch nachfragen wir
haben viel darüber gehört was die
personen die gesprächspartner von ihnen
auch lernen aber was lernen sie denn von
von diesen leuten angelaufen
das entschuldigung nicht ins wort
schlagen war war es so dass also ich bin
nach meinen beruf gerne ich bin auch ein
bescheidener mensch und ich bin so
dankbar für die vielen bereichen und
beeindruckende momente die ich in meiner
arbeit in der begegnung mit dem anderen
als menschen schon erleben durfte was
ich was mich nach wie vor enorm berührt
ist wenn leute die wirklich schwierigste
sachen erleben wie die sich ihre eigenen
verletzlichkeit nähern und gerade darin
eigentlich oft die kraft finden und mit
mit diesen schwierigen situationen
umzugehen und die leute ich finde auch
faszinierend mich darauf einzulassen die
wie die verschiedensten menschen auf
ganz verschiedene art und weise im leben
stehen und sich den dingen gegenüber
verhalten und sich auf den weg begeben
untersuchen
das ist das ist faszinierend es ist
unglaublich lehrreich ich frage mich
wenn menschen so viel mit solchen
personen die in totalen
krisensituationen oder in den sterbenden
situationen sind begegnen viel mit ihnen
zu tun haben gespräche führen wie sie
beide hat man dann noch angst vor dem
tod
sie kennen ja den schönen satz ich habe
nicht angst vor dem eigenen tod aber den
anderen und oder man ist wenn der eigene
tod
es geht mir persönlich so auch vor
operationen da kann ich wunderbar
eingehen und denken könnte ich jetzt so
gehen unter täglich doch aber angst
macht mit natürlich familiäres umfeld
freunde freundinnen
mein vater ist das ganz ähnlich
angst vor dem eigenen tor habe ich
eigentlich nicht aber es ist ich hab
selber auch schon in meiner umgebung
damit gibt miterlebte wie menschen die
mir sehr nahe standen gestorben sind das
ist das ist eine große herausforderung
und ich denke was mein eigenes leben
betrifft angst vor dem sterben das ist
noch etwas anderes finde ich also vom
tod sein ich persönlich geht es nicht
also ich weiß nicht ob es nach dem tod
noch was geben wird oder nicht ich gehe
in erster linie davon aus dass es auch
nicht so die große rolle spielt ob jetzt
mein persönliches leben weitergeht oder
nicht
also man das denke ich davon aus dass
ich sowieso auch weiter lebe in dem was
ich hinterlasse in der erinnerung
anderer menschen in tastbar uns und
immateriell das ist ja schon biblisch ja
es ist also das ist also ob ich jetzt
selber aufstehen also für mich spielt
das spielt es keine rolle aber es ist
also davon meinem eigenen sterben da
wünsche ich mir natürlich schon dass das
nicht also janka sident prozess spricht
ja genau was ich kurz hinzufügen wollte
zu dem was sie fordern so sehr schön
geschrieben haben also meinem empfinden
nach sehr schön geschrieben haben dass
verankert sein wo sie fragt und es gibt
ja diese vielen studien die deutlich
machen dass jemand der auf was
bestimmtes zurückgreifen kann in der
also gerade beim sterben dass das hilft
oder dass es sich bei der genesung wenn
genesung noch möglich ist dem stimme ich
absolut zu ich denke es wichtig ist dass
verankert sein und auch da ist es
natürlich so dass meines erachtens in
meinem empfinden nach dass auch menschen
die nicht an gott glauben durchaus also
solange sie verankert sind also dass die
verankerung wichtig ist aber dass es
nicht unbedingt gut sein muss dass für
manche menschen gott sehr wertvoll sein
kann
das steht für mich außer frage das ist
einfach hinzufügen dass es nicht immer
gut sein muss
wir sind leider schon am ende des
gesprächs ich möchte eine letzte frage
an sie stellen und zwar hat valentin
abgottspon dessen der vizepräsident der
schweizer freidenker vereinigung in
einem radiointerview zur seelsorge
gesagt er habe keine seele und da gehe
davon aus dass wir alle auch keine seele
haben
und deswegen frau 1000 fr not haben die
denn eine seele ganz kurz so wie frau
note des foreign beschrieben hat schöner
könnte ich selber nicht formulieren dann
würde ich eher sagen ich habe keine
seele ich bin seele so wie sie das
formuliert hat mit elektrischen ich das
kann ich nur übernehmen und sagen die im
guten sprechen denken genau wunderbar da
haben sich zwei gefunden
vielen dank für das gespräch von otpor
1000 mein kollege wolfram eilenberger
wurde vom peruanischen schriftsteller
und nobelpreisträger mario vargas llosa
in seinem haus nach madrid zum gespräch
eingeladen
das sehen sie jetzt gleich in der
sternstunde philosophie einen schönen
sonntag und des demnächst
[Musik]